herr kummer wir haben es gerade gehört
sachsens innenminister sagt es gab keine
rechtliche grundlage
den terroristen für 24 stunden zu
überwachen und selbst wenn dann hätte
das den mord nicht verhindert ist das
tatsächlich so einfach kann man es sich
so einfach machen also zunächst einmal
bin ich jetzt weit weg davon
ihre verantwortung oder schuld zuweisen
dazu kennen wir noch nicht genügend
details dieses falles aber der
sächsische innenminister hat zu recht
die frage des abschiebestopps
angesprochen und das ist natürlich das
hauptproblem dass uns hier im wege steht
wenn die effektivste maßnahme sind
aufenthaltsbeendende maßnahmen
ich sage es immer wieder ausländerrecht
ist sicherheit recht und das kann man an
der stelle sehr deutlich sehen und
deshalb müssen wir an dieses thema jetzt
dringen dran
sie sagen an dieses thema müssen wir
dringend dran wie sieht denn das aus wie
schnell kann so was umgesetzt werden
na ja wie gesagt also der abschiebestopp
läuft ende des jahres aus
es ist ja jederzeit möglich dass die
bundesregierung jetzt regelungen trifft
um die abschiebungen auch zu vollziehen
technisch ist es in soweit möglich als
es natürlich flugverbindungen gibt über
beirut können sie ohne weiteres nach
damaskus fliegen mit geschäftsreisende
machen das jeden tag
und insofern wäre es technisch möglich
es muss das problem gelöst werden dass
wir dazu natürlich irgendwie eine
zumindest technische verbindung zum
syrischen staates herstellen müssen
sowohl das muss keine diplomatische aber
das muss nicht technische sein damit
diese abschiebung auch praktisch
abgewickelt werden kann
und dann ist das möglich wie schätzen
sie das ganze ein fels der
abschiebestopp noch bis zur
bundestagswahl offen
ich hoffe dass wir das thema dieses noch
in diesem jahr gelöst bekommen
ich meine wir kommen doch an einen punkt
an dem wird das den menschen auch nicht
mehr erklären können dass jemand den wir
bei uns aufnehmen um ihn vor gewalt
droht zerstörung und vertreibung in
seiner heimat zu schützen
eben jene zustände bei uns einführen
will das ist doch geradezu ja das ist
doch grotesk wie wollen sie das den
menschen noch erklären
das heißt wenn ich sie richtig verstehe
unterstützen sie die these dass
konsequentes abschieben von
strafgefangenen ausländern menschen
leben in deutschland rettet
ich unterstütze die these nicht nur ich
sagte dass seit jahren und das ist auch
absolut richtig so
wenn jemand uns hier gefährdet
dann gibt es nur eine einzige antwort
nämlich um den hals nach hause
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren